back everyone for the second day of the
mathematics of online decision making
workshop so our first speaker for this
morning
is tsuchi charla from university of
wisconsin-madison
and she's gonna tell us about pandora's
okay thanks seb so you can hear me uh
well okay great um okay
thanks uh so this is uh i'm gonna talk
about joint work with my colleague
christos zamos
and students uh eva gergezoli
he fang tang and roman zhang and this is
going to appear at fox in a
a few days and let me get a laser
pointer great
okay so i'm going to talk about the
pandora's box problem and
many of you know what this problem is
but let me
go over it nevertheless so here we are
given
uh this is an online problem and we're
given
a number of boxes that contain rewards
in them
and it's a so it's a stochastic online
problem
so the rewards are going to be random
and they're drawn from known
distributions
so these are the distributions here and
we can
our goal is to pick the box that has the
most reward we want to maximize the
reward
we obtain and we can only pick one and
before we make that decision we can open
each box and observe the reward
in it at some fixed penalty so the t's
here
are the penalties for opening the boxes
so we may for example
decide to open box one at a cost of t1
and then this instantiates uh some
reward from this distribution
um and then observing this we might
decide
uh to go ahead and open box three at a
cost of t3
and then there's some reward realized
here uh
and then at this point we might decide
to stop and accept
uh the reward in box three and the
process terminates
and our goal is to maximize the reward
we
obtain minus how much we pay in this
probing penalty so in this example this
would be
r3 minus the sum of t1 and t3
that's the standard pandora's box
problem
now in this talk we're going to look at
the minimization version of it
so instead of rewards we have costs uh
so the pictures here are not quite right
now
but we have costs drawn from these known
distributions
and this time around we want to minimize
uh the sum of the cost in the box we
pick
and the probing penalties we pay okay so
the sum of these
so that's the problem uh we want to look
at
and the question here is
uh we need to decide both the order in
which we want to probe boxes
as well as a stopping rule that tells us
when to stop opening boxes and pick the
best one of the ones we've found so far
okay so this is a a fairly
old problem that's been studied
extensively and in particular
weizmann look looked at this and back in
79 gave a very nice and simple algorithm
and this algorithm basically said well
you can compute
a sort of amortized cost or the kittens
index for each box independently
and then we probe boxes in the
minimization version
we're going to probe boxes in greedy
order of increasing
amortized cost and then we're going to
stop as soon as
the observed cost in a probed box is
smaller than
all of the remaining indices and that's
the box we would
select and it turns out that this
algorithm is optimal if it's the case
that the distributions
of costs across the different boxes are
independent
okay so that's great and there's been a
lot of work
on variations of this sort of
simple model where you might have
different kinds of cost structures and
feasibility
constraints and so on and uh the same
sort of template for this algorithm
continues to work
in those settings now in this talk we
are going to be
interested in a setting where the the
costs across
the different boxes are correlated so
there's some distribution
um which is a joint distribution over
these vectors
of costs and we want to consider the
same question of how to probe and when
to stop
in order to minimize this cost plus
probing penalty
and observe that since this is a joint
distribution now this can be
pretty complicated and with a very large
support
and so uh we're not going to be given
direct access to this distribution uh so
there's
a another added interesting component to
this question now which is
um you know can we learn a good
algorithm or a good policy for
uh this setting if we're given sample
access to this distribution
okay and how many samples do we need in
order to learn
a good policy so that's that's the focus
of this uh
talk so we are looking both at the
learning aspect of this question
how many samples how do we learn from
these samples
and the the approximation or
optimization
uh aspect of this question can we find
the optimal policy and if not can we
find an approximately optimal policy
okay okay and please interrupt
feel free to interrupt me if you have
any questions throughout
the talk but let's first talk about
you know what does a policy here look
like so
a policy has two components you need to
find the order in which to probe boxes
and you need to find the stopping time
and both of these can be functions of
what we've observed so far so
the probing order what you probe at the
ith step can depend on
because the costs are correlated this
can depend on what you
observe in the first i minus 1 steps
this can tell you give you some
information about
the conditional distribution over costs
of the remaining boxes and likewise the
time at which you stop
uh also depends on these
observed costs but whenever you stop you
should just
select the the box with the smallest
cost observed so far
uh so just expressing the objective
formally we're just minimizing
um we're going to make this simplifying
assumption for this talk that every
uh box has a probing penalty of one
so we're just minimizing the stopping
time plus this
smallest cost we've seen so far
okay um now
describe you can so we can think of this
uh policy as this kind of giant
decision tree and sort of the very first
question that comes to mind is uh you
know this
optimal policy could be
very very complicated and it's not even
clear
that this is expressible uh in
uh the some compact uh form
and uh so in fact it turns out that in
this
correlated setting learning this optimal
policy
is pretty much a hopeless task and
here's uh
an example to keep in mind so
let's imagine that um the costs are
correlated in the following manner
so we're going to have some large number
of boxes
and except for the first box the costs
and all of the other boxes are going to
be 0 or infinity
so this is one particular instantiation
of the cost vector so what's going to
happen
is that in every particular
instantiation there's going to be
one box that has a zero cost and
everything else is going to have
infinite cost and so really we're
looking for this one box that has
uh zero cost and furthermore it's going
to turn out to be the case that
the identity of the zero cost uh box is
going to be encoded somehow in the cost
of the first box
so if only we could somehow
invert this encoding of
this index i we could just probe the
first box and
then invert this encoding learn the
identity
of this i and then probe
this box and be done and so this has
a probing penalty of 2 it has a cost of
0
so the the optimum is just 2. but if we
didn't know how to invert this function
f and this is some hard to invert
function it's not clear that you can
learn
this inversion with few samples
okay so when where the learning question
uh is concerned
this is basically a hopeless problem and
so we somehow need to change the problem
somehow to make progress
and so what we do in this work is to
make the case for uh competing against
a simpler benchmark and not the overall
optimal policy which is uh
basically unachievable uh without any
further assumptions
and i want to quickly mention here that
this
problem is also closely closely related
to
work on optimal decision trees and
related problems but there's a crucial
difference here which is
that that literature uh typically
assumes
uh that the distribution over possible
um so here we have cost vectors or you
can think of these as scenarios
and the distribution over these
scenarios is a small support
distribution so it's explicitly given
and when it's explicitly given of course
this sort of example goes away
but in those works the um the
approximability of the problem then also
depends on the support size so
the focus of this work is a little bit
different it's on
distributions that are arbitrarily
complicated but
where we are hoping to compete against a
simpler benchmark
okay so uh what is this simpler
benchmark
um so we're going to uh think uh
uh back to the uh the original pandora's
box uh setting
for inspiration and recall that
in the original setting with uh
independent costs
uh independent distributions across
different boxes
uh the optimal policy turns out to be
particularly simple
uh in particular you know it computes
indices for the different boxes
and then it always opens boxes in uh
order of uh sorted indices uh so it's
what we would call
a partially adaptive policy so let me
define what i mean by partially adaptive
so again a policy here is this pair
of a probing order and a stopping time
and we're going to call a policy
partially adaptive if the probing order
is independent of the instantiations of
costs
okay so you look at the samples from the
distribution and then based on
what we know about the distribution we
construct a fixed
we determine a fixed probing order and
we're always going to probe boxes in
this
particular fixed order but then
our decision for when to stop can still
be a function of
what we've observed okay so the order is
fixed but the stopping time
depends on instantiations and that's the
sense in which this is
uh partially adaptive and by the way we
could think of non-adaptive policies in
this context as
those that also have a fixed stopping
time that's independent of
instantiations and that
corresponds to basically probing
a fixed subset of boxes and probing all
of them at once
and then deciding which one to pick
okay so um
when the costs are independent across
boxes
then it so happens that partially
adaptive probing
strategies are optimal across the
class of all possible strategies even
fully adaptive ones
but when costs are correlated they're
not necessarily
optimal and our goal will be to compete
against the simpler class
of uh probing strategies so that's our
new benchmark it's the optimal partially
adaptive probing strategy
okay and i want to point out here that
even though the probing order here
is fixed and it's not adaptive
the stopping rule is adaptive and so
um these uh these policies can also be
uh fairly complicated uh and can depend
on
uh very complicated ways
on uh the costs that have been observed
so far
so it's again not entirely clear whether
the optimal partially adaptive policy
can be learned
or represent learn with low sample
complexity or represented
succinctly okay
so uh my main result
which is in joint work with
these folks at wisconsin is that we can
indeed learn an approximately
optimal partially adaptive strategy
and we can do this efficiently and with
low sample complexity
okay so there are uh
three components to uh this uh
main result and let me describe them in
some detail
so what our work shows is that
we can identify a simple class of
partially adaptive strategies that have
the
following properties so first of all
this simple class is going to contain
for any instance an approximately
optimal strategy
and so if we could just learn the
optimal policy with few samples over the
simple class
then this would also be approximately
optimal
second uh this class in some sense has
low complexity and so
it can be learned using a polynomial in
n n here's the number of boxes it can be
learned using polynomially many
samples and samples here
i should clarify are cost vectors drawn
from the
joint distribution so from the joint
distribution every time we draw a sample
this is a vector over
m costs and we draw polynomially many
such
samples and so the distribution itself
could be
very very complex and there is no
um sort of bound on how large the costs
could be
but we can nevertheless learn the
optimal strategy in this class
and finally once we draw these samples
then
we get a small support empirical
distribution
over costs and now we can optimize with
respect to this
small support distribution and uh we can
efficiently approximate the optimal
strategy and see
ah over this distribution to within some
small constant okay so these three
components together give us
uh an efficient uh
learning result for an approximately
optimal strategy
okay so in the rest of this talk i'm
going to
uh be able to show you uh proof for you
in fact theorems
one and two entirely with theorem one
with a slightly worse
uh approximation factor and theorem
three i will
uh just say a few words about but i will
really not go into much detail
on this okay
so let me describe what this uh
simple class of partially adaptive
strategies
is um and recall that a partially
adaptive strategy
uh again it requires specifying
what the probing order is and it also
requires specifying
what the stopping rule is and what we're
going to do
for this simple class is to simplify the
stopping rule
so what is our stopping rule um
we are going to so any strategy in this
class will be parameterized by some
probing order and we're going to probe
boxes
until it's the case that we find some
solution or we find some box which has
instantiated cost
that's smaller than the probing penalty
we've paid so far
and then we're going to stop and i'll
just call this the myopic stopping rule
and uh note that it's very reminiscent
of the
this key rental uh algorithm
and indeed it really uh you know this is
really
uh just an extension of the the ski
rental
analysis um but before we
go into that let me just point out that
uh you know with this
fixed um
sort of stopping rule here the number of
different strategies
in this class c is just n factorial
one for each particular ordering and
furthermore because our probing cost
always
lies between one and n it's one per box
uh the the cost of any strategy
uh is bounded um and so this uh
this immediately gives us basically
theorem 2 with
a tiny bit of effort and so the learning
follows just from the fact that this
class is small
okay now why is this approximately
optimal so as i said this is
very much like a ski rental kind of
argument so uh you know let's say that
ai describes the in smallest
instantiated cost we've found so far so
over time as we probe more and more
boxes uh this cost
this best cost ai decreases
and this orange line here is
our probing penalty so this increases at
some rate
at every point of time and our stopping
rule basically says
asks us to stop precisely when the
orange
line crosses the blue curve and this
gives us a total cost the sum of these
that is twice basically twice the
stopping time
and the observation is that anywhere
else
so if we go below this stopping time if
we stopped earlier
the probing cost would be um i'm sorry
if we stopped earlier the
the cost of the solution would be larger
and if we stopped later the probing
penalty would be larger so
one or the other of these uh would be
larger than
uh the corresponding amount here
and so this gives us a factor of 2
approximation
okay so that was
fairly straightforward and so really the
key thing here was to identify
the simple class of strategies that
always contains an approximately optimal
one and can be learned
with few samples um and then the third
question is you know how do you actually
learn this
based on a small support distribution
and i want to just make a quick comment
here
which is that actually this
proof of theorem one that i showed you
is very very robust so it
continues to hold uh under uh
other feasibility constraints it
continues to hold when probing penalties
are set functions as long as they're
they're polynomially bounded
and so it's really
an argument that extends to many
different settings
okay so then now the final component
of our solution is this efficient
optimization
over uh this class c so
in this context now where we draw some
uh
m number of scenarios from the given
distribution
so each scenario or each sample now is
this vector of costs
and our goal is to find a permutation
such that if we if we look at this
policy
that uses that permutation and the
myopic stopping
uh rule uh then this is approximately
optimal over this class c
with respect to this uh empirical
distribution over scenarios
okay so that's the goal and
it's a little bit challenging to capture
what myopic stopping would do in this
uh setting um and so instead of
myopic stopping what we do is we're
going to find a permutation
pi such that if we
were to use a hindsight optimal stopping
this would be approximately or optimal
over
the class of all policies with hindsight
optimal stopping so what do i mean by
hindsight optimal stopping
i mean that uh we are going to
uh you know look at this sequence of
instantiated costs
and for every scenario s we're going to
imagine that we instantiate
all of the costs and then pick the
optimal place to stop for that
particular scenario for that particular
instantiation and we're going to call
this
this
a scenario-aware partially adaptive
strategy
so of course this falls outside of um
our class of partially adaptive
strategies that we established before
because this is more powerful
it's allowed to pick its uh stopping
rule in the scenario aware fashion
and this extra power is going to help us
uh do this approximation uh
efficiently and then the previous um
result i showed you uh the two
approximations still holds so myopic
stopping is still going to be within
a factor of two of hindsight optimal
stopping
okay so we're gonna optimize over
scenario aware
partially adaptive strategies now and
uh to do this we i want to point out
a connection to this previous line of
work on the min sum
set cover problem um so this is actually
a special case
of uh the this uh
problem that we're looking at so what is
the special case so if all of the costs
in the boxes
are zero or infinity then our goal
becomes to basically
uh you know find a zero cost box so we
want to open boxes in such a fashion
that we
that in every scenario we can quickly
find
a zero cost box and as soon as we find
it we can identify it and then we can
stop
um and so this uh special case is
precisely the min sum set cover problem
and there's a lot of work
uh on this problem and and many variants
of it that have been studied
and i mentioned this connection because
um
our algorithm for this approximation is
uh in some sense very closely related to
the lp
rounding algorithms that have been
developed for this problem
although we do need to take some care to
handle
arbitrary costs so basically what our
algorithm does is to
write down an lp over this empirical
distribution over
m scenarios um and uh don't worry about
looking at this uh closely basically
what this does is it has permutation
constraints for the probing order
um and then we're talking about scenario
aware
partially adaptive strategies and so
this lp sets up variables for
whether or not to stop and
pick a box based on what scenario
uh we're in or what uh cost vector
uh we're at um and so that's what this
uh
set of constraints does it's a set of
constraints that establishes
which box is selected and when we stop
uh depending on what the scenario is um
and then we basically want to round uh
this lp
in a manner that the
the rounding of the probing order is
independent of the scenarios
but the selection of boxes uh depends
very much on the scenario
that we are in okay and i won't go into
that rounding
okay so let me just uh wrap up uh with
our results
so the setting that i mostly talked
about is a setting where
you get to select one box and we get
some constant factor approximation there
and we also get constant factor uh
approximations for
the a more general setting where we can
select up to k boxes
and uh we can also extend all of this to
a more general setting where we have a
metroid feasibility constrained
on what boxes we can select and then
it becomes possible to get an
approximation that depends
logarithmically on the rank of the
metroid
and the uh the algorithm in each of
these settings
is uh pretty much similar uh
to what i described before so we first
draw these polynomially
in n many samples from the distribution
and then we set up an lp on these
samples and solve this
lp and then we use a rounding
algorithm and i didn't describe what the
surrounding is
but there's a rounding algorithm for
each of these contexts where we can find
a good probing order
and this gives us an approximately
optimal
scenario aware partially adaptive policy
that is approximately optimal over these
polynomially many samples and then
we use it over the actual input
drawn from this distribution with the
myopic stopping
rule to get the final policy
okay so that's the algorithm and
again i in this talk i focused on
the setting where the probing penalties
are one for each box but you can
generalize
this to a setting where different boxes
have different
probing penalties and let me also
mention
that these are all tight within constant
factors
and they're even tight if you
look at a simpler approximation question
which is
you know i want to approximate not the
optimal
partially adapted policy but just the
optimal non-adaptive policy which is
even weaker
than the optimal partially adapted
policy so i want to approximate
something weaker
and maybe i even want to do this with
the full power of a fully adaptive
policy
okay and it turns out that it's
computationally hard
to do so within factors uh better than
these
uh ones and this hardness is it's all
based off of the hardness of set cover
there is a question yeah
um mayank i think you can speak
yeah hi can you uh hear me
yes go ahead yeah uh uh so
i had a query with respect to the spa
versus n a
uh uh scenarios uh
uh do we have uh uh
uh some sort of uh uh different
convex uh optimization uh
uh scenarios for uh both or uh
do we uh have a
similar cost or an objective function
that can
minimize it so are you asking about
just optimizing over non-adaptive
policies
yes you know what is that yeah so it
turns out that if you just wanted to
optimize over non-adaptive policies that
generalizes set cover
so approximating non-adaptive policies
with non-adaptive policies is even
harder than
uh than these so here we are using the
extra power that partial adaptivity
gives us
um okay and so uh so it's actually
interesting that
approximating nao using n a
is hard approximating fully adaptive
using fully adaptive
is hard but approximating partially
adaptive using partially adaptive
uh becomes much easier
thanks sure
okay so let me quickly wrap up since i'm
uh out of time
uh so uh you know there are lots of
interesting open questions here
uh but i want to finish with this uh one
uh sort of uh that i find to be an
interesting direction for data-driven
algorithm design which is
identifying a class of algorithms that
on the one hand gives us approximate
optimality and on the other hand
is learnable because of having low
complexity
in some way and i put complexity in
ports because you can
think of this in many different ways but
i think this is a nice direction
for data driven algorithm design and i
will skip talking about open directions
but happy to talk about this
uh offline thanks sushi uh so we have
one
question by david goldberg
yeah so um i was wondering
if uh if you had a black box such that
for any
fixed order you could actually solve
that
complex optimal stopping problem
is it clear how one could start to think
about
plugging that into your framework
because
the lp relaxation kind of is with
respect to this
hindsight kind of optimum not the actual
optimal value so is it do you have any
thoughts on how one could maybe uh
try to try to plug that in yeah so
the lp really what it does is uh it says
that
if i only have a few scenarios or you
know small support uh
distribution then i can actually imagine
uh so this is of course a power that the
algorithm
doesn't have but it says you know just
as far as it goes
as you know thinking about the probing
order goes i can actually
imagine that i have this full power of
having a scenario a wear stopping rule
and then i can actually up uh you know
optimize over the probing order
and once you do that then you can ask
well now that i have fixed the probing
order
how do i find a good stopping rule and
that's where something better could
come into play um but if i was directly
optimizing for the probing order with
respect to a different stopping rule
that becomes a different approximation
question and i it's not clear that
uh one can do that does that answer your
question
i think so i guess i was more
specifically wondering like
like let's say you literally had that
block box right
then if i if i think about the approach
you did
since the lp has baked into it
this spa it would not be clear
how to shave off an e over e minus one
anywhere
be or at least not not kind of
immediately clear because it would seem
that
even if you could solve that problem for
any fixed order
in principle you still had this baseline
from your lp which was only with respect
to the
best in hindsight and it wouldn't be
obvious how how to connect the dots
there
yeah that's that's exactly right so i
wouldn't know how to
write an lp necessarily for a different
uh uh approach even if you had that
blackboard even if we had that black box
yes that's exactly right yeah
thank you maybe we keep the rest of the
discussion
for the discussion period and we can
move on to the next talk thanks again
suchi ishai if you want to share your